truth is that most children who are
unhappy with their sex grow out of it
and the main thing that they need to do
is go through puberty and that's what
gender and affirming care
won't let you do you're put on puberty
blockers and that itself is medically
highly dubious can lead to Bone thinning
and it inhibits of mental development
the puberties it may be confusing it may
be often unpleasant and you know it
feels like your body's being taken over
which it is it's being taken over by
adulthood but it's medically vital
and we started interfering with it
at scale without any real research on
what the consequences are and I think
that down the road we're probably going
to be looking at class action suits by a
lot of very unhappy young adults
who want to come to some understanding
as to how they were allowed to do this
or why this was done to them